D
-- THEN HOLD ON TO IT LIKE
CROSBY DID
THERE'S RO
>> BEAUTIFUL MOVE HERE BY
BIG TIMEHAND AND STAY ON THE
SHORT SIDE WITH THE PU
WELL I  AND ONE IN
HIS CAREER JARRY IS TWO AND ONE
IN HIS CAREER.
SO EASY.
YOU KNOW SHESTERKIN,
MAKING THAT ONE LOOKPLAYERS DOID
EASY.BLUES AND HE COMES IN.
HE SCORES, THEY CAN GO
HERE.
BJORKSTRAND, THE RIGHT-HANDED
SHOT DOWN THE LEFT>> Jody: NICER
SHELF.AKES HIS WAYE GOT THE CHIH
DUCHENE SCORES IN THE SHOOTOUT.
GETS THE GO-AHEAD.
PICKS IT UP AT CENTER.
RIGHT WING. HANDED.
JOHNNY GAUDREAU, 5 OF INNER A S
THIS ONE.
>> Dennis: SO THE FLAMES GO WITH
BACK-TO-BACK WINS AFTER THE WINE
AS HE DID LAST NIGHT, ON THE BAK
AND, NOT HAPPY HIS SOCKS AND GO
BACK HAND, AMOV.
HE'S GOING TO LOSE HIS FOOTOTIN
SCORES!
OH, THE FOREHAND, AN COUTURIER
TO EVEN THINGS UP.SCORES EXTRA
A BEAUTIFUL MOVE BY COUTURIER
EXTRA OAL
VRBATA.
LEFT-HANDED SHOT COMES IN ON TH
SCSC
LOOK AT THIS. THIS ONE
IN.HE SHOT. PRACTICED
ALAL IN GIVE
THE LEAD TO OTTAWA HERE, IT IS
STÜTZLE, SKATING IN, SHOTT
THE HANDS ANDP FORSBERG.
TO THE TO WIN IT!
ROMAN JOSI HAS OETTINGER BEAT
LIKE A RENTED MULE, AND JUST
H
HAVE BEEN ON THE ROOF, NCOMES.
WIDE RIGHT IN ON BRAND HOTEL.
TAKENOT,
THAT IS ONLY THE SECOND SHOOTOUT
GOAL THE M29% IN HIS CAREER.
HERE COMES TATAR.
HECK OF A MOVE ON HOLTBY.TOUT,
CAROLINA HURRICANES, OVER THE
BOARDS, DOUGIE HAMILTON.
WHO IS TWO FOR FOUR.
INAND SCORES!
>> Matt: JOONAS DONSKOI HAS BEEE
BOOTH JUST WATCHING
SCORES!
GAME OVER!ORAK PULLED THIS ONE F
HIS BAG OF TRICKS.
POWERUST WHAT WE
CALLLIE COYLE.
>> Andy: AND THAT IS
NOT ONE STRAIGHT TO THE
DEVILS.
THERE ONLY WIN HAS
CO
>> Andy: KIND OF
REMINDS YOU OF
EARLIER IN THE YEAR
WHERE THE BRBRORES!
E IT.
AND NOW WE STILLDOWN . HE SHOOT.
HE
JARRY HEADED TO THE CORNER.
THE CAPTAIN TIES I I
YES, FROM COUTURIER THERE TO
GET THE FLYERS A 2-1 LEAD IN FI.
SEE IF HE GOES
AND THEN PULLED IT.
WATCH THE L QUICKLY.
DEKES, HE SCORES!PRESERVER,
THE FLYERS SCORED THE FIRST TWO
OPPORTUNITIES.
ANGLE BY ELLIOT.
>> Jim: KEVIN HAYES SECOND
HAND
GREAT LTON HAS GIVEN TAMPA THE
.
>> M
THEM AND A FORMER LIGHTNA WAY T
PUTTING IT ON THE BACK AND
SHOULD GO
AND SCORES ON THE BACKHAND.